hey guys Pete here this will be my
watchman episode six recap with thoughts
about what we just learned episode six
was titled this extraordinary being
which was an excerpt of Hollis Mason's
description of hooded justice in his
in-universe book under the hood the
episode was directed by Stephen Williams
and written by court Jefferson and Damon
Lindelof we go back in time to live will
Reeves as memories through his
granddaughter Angela a bar who took his
bottle of pills at the end of the last
episode wills origin story turns out to
be the origin story of watchmen itself
the story of how people started wearing
costumes and masks to fight crime which
is what altered the history of the
universe at the show exists in the
reveal that will is hooded justice
worked even though I was somewhat
skeptical about it when the theory first
popped up before we go down the rabbit
hole with Angela we do get a version of
the story of the Minutemen through the
in universe TV show American heroes
Story Minutemen we find out that Agent
Dayle PD's concern about the show being
inaccurate our spot-on as we watch the
fictionalized interrogation of hooded
justice I like how this plays out and
that we're all wondering if it's gonna
be a black man with white makeup around
his eyes even though we know it's not
the show insiders show shocking reveal
seems to be that captain metropolis was
having an affair with J Edgar Hoover
which may or may not be true but through
Angela's experience we find out what's
really going on with the Minutemen will
Reeves witnessed the race massacre in
Tulsa as a boy which is how episode 1 of
the HBO watchman series open he was also
president when Chief Judge Crawford hung
himself which is how episode 1 ended in
one hour episode 6 fills in what
happened in between to start him on his
journey that gets him to the point where
he hypnotizes Judd under that tree we
start at a Police Academy graduation in
1938 and we get this shifting
perspective as will and Angela take
turns playing the point-of-view role
this technique underlines the idea
behind nostalgia and connecting the
present with the past and it's the
closest thing to walking in someone's
shoes that you could imagine we don't
know how we'll end it up here from the
field outside of Tulsa but we do learn
the
the baby he found there turned out to be
his wife June June plays the part of
painting the picture of who will has
become while his chosen profession of a
police officer paints what he's up
against the violence he experienced and
the loss of his family at a young age
have made will an angry man according to
his wife but his love for bass Reeves
drove him to pursue his dream job of
being a cop as he takes in a man for
casually lobbing a Molotov cocktail
through the window of a Jewish
delicatessen we get a look into the vast
and insidious conspiracy as other police
officers take over the investigation and
the man goes free later the same dirty
cops with ties to the Cyclops group
which appears to be a sort of extension
of the Ku Klux Klan beat will up in
stage and lynching before cutting him
down at the very last minute all to
instill fear in him and keep him in line
saying keep your black nose out of white
people's business the fact that we see
Angela on the ground really emphasizes
the generational effects of this kind of
terror after the incident hooded justice
is born and will decides to put the hood
back on before he intervenes saving
victims of an assault he happens upon on
his way home this is huge in relation to
the Canon of the story as it relates to
this show and as mentioned I think it
actually works will deciding to put on
the hood in the moment works just as
good as any explanation of how this
craze actually started he's a man
dealing with trauma that he has to hide
and he's obsessed with justice he can't
realize this justice through normal
avenues so he takes matters into his own
hands with the advice of his wife he
paints around his eyes to appear as a
white man under the hood and with that
costume adventuring is born if you've
never read the original comic this does
actually track with what was known about
hooded justice because there wasn't much
while it probably wasn't Alan Moore and
David Gibbons the original creators
intention for her - justice to be a
black man in white face it was their
intention for his identity to be a
mystery what is known about him comes
from under the hood which is an
in-universe book written by the second
costume adventurer Hollis Mason aka a
night owl based on this version of the
story it's very possible Hollis didn't
have much to go on in relation to who
hooded justice was when he wrote that
book rather than it being that he was
trying to cover something up in this
week's PDP dia files we get his reaction
to the reveal which is pretty fantastic
agent PD writes from historians
perspective the discovery of hooded
justices true identity as mr. Reaves
significantly reframes our understanding
of the history of masked vigilantes in
our country it forces me to confront my
own biases it never occurred to me to
consider that hooded justice could have
been anything other than a white male as
Athena sprung from the head of Zeus so
did the modern phenomenon of costumed
vigilantes emoted justice for century
his secret identity is the only one that
has remained unrevealed and now we know
why it seems clear that mr. Reeves did
not hide his face for purposes of
showmanship or pageantry but for his own
survival what I love most about this is
the way American hero story which is
based off under the hood acts as a
mirror in how the story is reflected in
popular culture the event that really
kicked off the whole idea of costume
adventuring was the incident at the
market in the show we've now seen two
different versions of how that played
out one where hooded justice jumps in
through the window to save the shop
owner and customers inside from
criminals and the other where he jumps
out of the window to get away after he
beats up the Klansmen in the back room
the release of Action Comics number one
in the reporting in the newspaper on
this incident is what convinced Hollis
Mason that he had to become the world's
second costume adventurer and I really
enjoyed how it was based on something
that was completely misinterpreted after
that incident will is eventually
approached by Nelson Gardner aka captain
metropolis who's putting together the
Minutemen Nelson like all of us watching
the show has a theory his theory that
will is the cop who is feeding hooda
justice his information turns out to
only be part of that story the two get
to know each other they end up hooking
up and will becomes one of the Minutemen
the idea of them being secret lovers was
hinted at in the original story and we
see how that came to be in this section
Will's motivation to bring down the
Cyclops turns out to be incompatible
with the minute men's goals though as he
discovers a conspiracy to use mesmerism
to incite black-on-black
Islands after an incident in Harlem this
turns out to be a little bit more than
what the Minutemen want to get involved
with he arrives on the scene he figures
out what the Cyclops is up to and then
he calls captain metropolis for help and
taking care of it and shutting them down
metropolis says so the Klan is using
mind control do you have any idea how
ridiculous that sounds and once again we
see what wills up against this is where
things get interesting as far as the
story going ahead will is confronted
with the plan and the fact that they're
getting away with it he kills everyone
and burns down the warehouse and it
feels like justice what else could he do
the police are working with the group
behind all this and the Minutemen don't
want to get involved in the same way
that the white citizens of Tulsa bombed
and burned down the Greenwood
neighborhood will wipes out the Cyclops
his base of operations and he takes one
of their projectors with him it's an eye
for an eye type of justice that makes as
much sense as something like that can
given the circumstances
later he uses the same technology to get
chief Crawford to hang himself while
Crawford does have ties to the Cyclops
at least in his family this situation
feels a lot more like vengeance than
justice will does confront him about the
Klan robes in his closet he doesn't have
a great comeback other than they're a
part of his legacy but he is hypnotized
and because of that we don't get a
better explanation but rather a
statement that will doesn't know what's
really going on here that opens up the
door to there being more to the story
that wills overlooking it definitely
leaves you wondering if will has made a
mistake and that the conspiracy here
might be deeper than what we've seen in
the end that makes it a very fascinating
episode of television of course that
looked great the way they put it
together was great it's good as a
standalone but as far as the whole story
it reinforces this idea that there's
rarely black and white answers to
questions of good and evil in the
Supplemental materials we learned that
while Angela was experiencing all of
this she's also talking and Laurie was
there recording at all
that's how agent Petey knew about the
hooded justice reveal and when I think
was one of the key scenes we'll freaks
out after he sees his son trying to
dress up in his costume as he's trying
to wash the makeup off his face his wife
makes her
intentions to leave and go back to Tulsa
clear she says that she thought that
wearing the mask would help him get rid
of his anger but it didn't get rid of it
it just fed it that seems to be tied
into what this series is trying to say
it's still a little bit early to figure
out how they're going to get there from
where we're at right now but it also
makes that moment under the tree with
Crawford stand out it's not to say
Crawford was a good guy or he didn't
have it coming but it makes me wonder
how killing him is really going to make
a difference it gets me excited to see
how things are gonna come to a
conclusion and I guess now we are
heading into the ending of this
adventure angela has experienced the
things that got her grandfather into the
position of killing her boss as close to
firsthand as she could at this point as
she was going through all of that she
was talking out loud so Laurie was there
recording it they know who her
grandfather is at this point they know
what happened under the tree or at least
they have an idea of what they think
happened under the tree when Crawford
was killed which is this is a murder
investigation in the main story and we
see Angela wake up in the presence of
lady true who is definitely working
together with will and whatever he has
planned we have to imagine that she
knows everything that Angela knows and
that for whatever reason that made will
the person that she wanted to work with
in this project but we really can't say
for sure what her motivation is there is
an article about her in the PDP dia
which I'm not really gonna talk about
here but we get a little bit more of a
backstory and what's probably going on
with the character who she refers to as
her daughter later this week when I do
my trailer breakdown I'll talk about
that there that seems like a more
fitting place this episode had us look
at some uncomfortable truths and I think
it did a pretty good job I really like
the way that they connected the past and
the present how they connected Angela to
will and I'm really interested to see
what you guys think let me know in the
comments what you think about the big
reveal here what do you think lady true
and we'll are going to get up to now
that you've seen this episode I think it
has recalibrated some of my thoughts
about what they're up to but but like I
said I think I'll get into that and the
from video later this week and let this
set in because it's a pretty impressive
feat that they pulled off today and I
think I want to enjoy that for what it
is at this point let me know what you
guys think in the comments please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already I'll have a trailer break down
in a couple of days and hopefully some
bonus episodes to go along with that
this week thanks for watching I will
talk to you soon